blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman i do need to start today with an
apology
um for everything i've ever said on the
show
that has upset somebody uh no i'm
kidding i i want to apologize because
i did a little bit of a cleaning in the
studio you could call it sort of a
bleaching
you of sorts and i didn't realize
that two furniture elements
that are normally separated where my
microphone is connected to something
that is nowhere near
me just so i can't inadvertently create
any gunks
in the audio two thing two elements were
touching that should not have been
touching the last two days and i didn't
even realize that i was regularly
creating a sort of
a noise with the microphone people
sent me as you can imagine extremely
polite messages about it
and i've resolved it okay i've resolved
it so i do want to apologize for that
but let's not dwell on the negative we
are really starting to get to the next
phase which i would believe to be the
end
phase of the coronavirus pandemic as
cases are now down nearly 90 percent in
the united states
deaths are down nearly 85 percent
but but but vaccination continues to
slow down as there are now way more
vaccines
in the u.s than the number of people
that seem to want them at least
relatively quickly which is sad and
we're going to talk about that
much of that lack of demand is because
of republicans
this isn't a bipartisan thing four
percent of democrats don't want the
vaccine
41 percent of republicans don't want the
vaccine as we discussed yesterday
let's go through the case and death
numbers as we now have them cases in the
united states
peaking in mid-january around 255
000 a day now down to an average of 32
000 a day that is a decline of about 87
from that pandemic peak there are some
states where cases
are they're not literally zero
but they are almost statistically zero
places like
california that now have really really
low rates
and they're continuing down as more and
more people get vaccinated
in terms of deaths things are not yet
looking
as good deaths lag
changes in cases by about three to four
weeks
but nevertheless deaths are now down
about 82 percent from a pandemic peak in
late january
we were at 34.50 a day that's like
9 11 plus 10 every day
in deaths in late january we are now
down to just a hair over 600 deaths a
day still way too high to be calling
this anything close to over
but the right direction continues and
that direction is down
now one factor that is slowing down the
decline is that fewer and fewer people
are getting vaccinated each day
this is not because there aren't enough
vaccines or not enough appointments
just about every state many pharmacy
chains
chains many locations have switched to
just show up
no appointment needed just get over here
and we'll give you a vaccine
we have more than enough vaccines to go
around we have vaccines here
like countries around the world are
dreaming of having that's not an
exaggeration
but 41 of republicans
and 24 percent of all americans don't
want the vaccine
and so after peaking at about 3.3
million doses per day in early april
we have seen almost a 50 decline to now
just 1.8 million doses per day
this is embarrassing look around the
world
countries around the world are doing
everything they can
to get vaccines there are countries that
are happy to get half a million vaccines
we have millions and millions of them
just sitting around ready
and we have millions and millions
millions of people saying nah i don't
want to get one
the cases and the deaths would decline
way more quickly
if more people got vaccinated just think
we're vaccinating about half of the
number we were vaccinating a month ago
each day
we could be seeing cases decline
significantly faster if we just got back
to where we were
3.3 million vaccines per day we could
open everything sooner and more safely
if more people got vaccinated now what's
going on globally
because the u.s led from the standpoint
of
bad early in the pandemic we are now
leading from the standpoint of good in
terms of the vaccination
but the u.s is not the world what's
going on with global numbers
the good news is that global cases and
global deaths are now
clearly starting to come down 10 days
ago it looked like okay they were
leveling off but where will things go
globally cases peaked at about 830 000
cases per day in later april
we're now down to about 665 000 a day
it's an outrageous number
but it's down 20 from the peak that's
good
global deaths similarly to the picture
in the u.s
global deaths are declining but lagging
the case decline
global deaths peaked at about 14 000 a
day back in january can you imagine
almost got back there in april and we
are now down to about 12 000 deaths a
day that's a decline of 15
from the peak but there is a long way to
go
globally and part of why it's so
depressing to know
that we have the vaccines for everyone
but to see
in the united states people opting out
is that the vaccines are why the us
is doing better and better this is a
very similar thing to the measles
anti-vaxxers and it's
depressing doesn't even really cut it
you have measles anti-vaxxers who say
who dies of measles why would i go and
get my kid vaccinated for measles
the reason almost no one dies of measles
is the vaccination
campaign has been so effective and the
vaccine is so effective
were it not for that then people would
be dying of measles
people are saying some cases are going
down this is ending
i don't need to get the vaccine but the
reason why they're going down
is we have so many vaccines it's a
privilege to have access to so many
vaccines
an incredible headline multiple states
reported
zero covet deaths on single days over
the last week for the first time in
months
this includes arizona minnesota
massachusetts maryland and others
now of course weekend reporting can
throw off the meaning of any single
day's data
but the averages are declining things
are opening and that is all great
just go and get vaccinated it's free you
just show up there's a vaccine
available and maybe this will be more of
an incentive for people to get
vaccinated although i
think the people not getting vaccinated
don't care about this
the european union has announced hours
ago
they will be opening to vaccinated
americans let's talk about that next
uh this is a very personal story for me
i'm kind of kidding but people know i'm
supposed to go to a wedding in italy
in early september and i've been
wondering
will americans be allowed in uh the
uh washington post is now reporting that
the european union will be reopening
their borders
to the vaccinated american population
very very soon the european union
announced uh
this morning that they will be opening
the borders to vaccinated americans
after more than a year during which
travel has been
significantly restricted uh this is a
washington post report which says the
decision
will throw open europe's doors to
tourist business and other travel
after a long stretch in which most of
those from outside the 27 nation block
have not been allowed in it will hearten
those
i am feeling heartened i admit it it
will hearten those who have missed
wandering the continents ancient streets
as well as europeans whose livelihoods
depends on tourist
cash one final round of approvals is
necessary in the coming days but the
sign off is no longer in doubt
the plan was agreed upon by ambassadors
today the timing of when borders will
actually open is not yet clear but it
could be
within days and certainly by the end of
june
the european council quote now
recommends that rec
that member states ease restrictions in
particular for those
with an eu authorized vaccine that would
mean
all of the vaccines authorized in the
u.s
would get the green light but vaccines
currently manufactured in russia and
china that's the
sputnik and the sinovac vaccine would
not
at least at this time qualify you for
entry to the european union
this guidance from the european union is
not binding meaning a country could say
we're not letting anybody
in or a country could say we'll let
people in with the sputnik vaccine or
the sinovac vaccine or
the bleach injections or whatever they
want to do but this is the guidance from
the european union
uh it has been a massive struggle in
europe
greece opened relatively early um
croatia is open estonia uh
there are way i mean listen if the truth
is if you're determined
to go somewhere you can almost certainly
go and i know
you know 10 15 people who who have done
it i have friends who wanted to go visit
family in france france was allowing
people
coming from the uk the uk was allowing
americans with a 14-day quarantine so
they went to the uk hung out 14 days
worked remotely then went to france like
you you could do it all along
but that's not going to get the tourism
industry restarted so we are seeing a
definite change
at this point in time now you could you
will have a situation
where you will have vaccinated americans
going to countries
where the local population is not yet
highly vaccinated now per the cdc
although they have not yet
really changed country-specific travel
guidelines the cdc says
if you are vaccinated just about any
activity is safe even without a mask
although you should wear a mask in
certain situations as dictated by
local law regulation business policy
whatever a
third of eu residents have gotten at
least one dose of a vaccine
in the u.s about half of americans have
gotten at least one dose
so you will have it's basically six
weeks behind
europe is six weeks behind the united
states given how
slowly the initial vaccine rollout was
in europe
it's actually pretty good that they're
only six weeks behind
and there are going to be probably
significant accelerations as more and
more
vaccines will flow in the direction of
europe now i've said
for a while over time
the number of people who don't want the
vaccine in the u.s is going to decline
because there are going to be more and
more things you need to be vaccinated in
order to do um
one of those things now that you will be
able to do with vaccinated is go to
europe
i don't know that the anti-vax
republicans are that big on europe
and what i mean by that is a lot of the
same people
that still don't want a vaccine which is
41 of republicans
a lot of them are probably the types of
people who see the concept of europe as
sort of like
[ __ ] flamboyant and socialist and
they don't care about europe and they're
not interested in going to europe and in
fact
being told you can only go to europe
with a vaccine it might make them more
uh it might reinforce their anti-vaccine
beliefs
maybe not but we are seeing the decline
in anti-vaxx
slow down last month 43 percent of
republicans did not want the vaccine
this month it's 41 of republicans it is
a decline
but it's a very very slow decline so
great
news for who is this great news for this
is great news for would-be travelers
this is great news simply for those who
want to see
the world start to be able to come out
of what was a very dark winter
uh winter of 2020 um and hopefully
we will continue to see those cases and
deaths decline i i am cautiously
optimistic
that we will and we will all be
celebrating
on memorial day weekend not only with
maybe barbecues but also with a
crazy my accountant is saying david
don't do it
my staff is saying david don't even
think about it my
lawyer is saying i would reconsider but
i'm going to do it on memorial day
we are offering an historic memorial day
membership special
be notified of it on memorial day by
simply getting on my mailing list you go
to davidpakman.com
you type in your email address if you
know what it is and you will be notified
on memorial day
how do you do it instructions
forthcoming
on may 31st we'll take a quick break let
me know your thoughts about the
reopening
i'm on twitter at d pacman and we have a
really packed show for you today
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
let me very briefly remind you lest we
forget
that the david pakman show does depend
on the support of viewers and listeners
like you
to continue doing what we do and to
continue the expansion which will soon
include
a second youtube channel with new
content very exciting
you can sign up and uh participate in
the support
by getting a membership at
joinpakman.com the coupon code better21
does save you money if so uh desired
but i believe the normal prices are uh
really perfect they're really perfect
prices sign up at joinpakman.com
in a completely cowardly pathetic
disgusting but yeah absolutely
predictable move
house republican leaders are coming out
in opposition to even investigating what
happened on january 6th
with the trump riots in washington d.c
democrats and normal people
want to investigate january 6th because
it was an absolute
disgrace it was an outrageous tragic
moment in american history
and there are almost endless avenues of
investigation that should be pursued
who all participated who was responsible
who instigated what are the full
explanations for
delays in getting national guard and
more police to the capitol
who knew what and when the day of i
could go on and on but there are endless
avenues
of questions which i would love to see
answered and yet
republicans sent out a letter republican
leaders
sent out a letter to republican members
of congress yesterday trying to convince
them to vote against a bipartisan
proposal
to launch an investigation which in
structure could be similar to the 911
commission
house minority leader kevin mccarthy a
disgusting person
came out against the bipartisan deal
saying the scope of the investigation is
too narrow now
this is really i don't is this it's not
shrewd because shrewd almost has like a
positive connotation
maybe cynical you might think wow
kevin mccarthy thinks the investigation
is too narrow so clearly mccarthy wants
to investigate
more things about january 6. that sounds
good right
wrong republicans say in their letter
that to really investigate what happened
on january 6th
you need to investigate things that are
completely unrelated
like when steve scalise got shot at
baseball practice in 2017.
the letter that they wrote says quote
this commission cannot investigate the
political violence leading up to and
following the attack on the sixth
including the june 2017 shooting at the
republican congressional baseball
practice
and the deadly attack on capitol police
on april 2 2021.
the report is due too late to properly
educate and advise
on securing the capital complex and
there is no def
prohibition against indefinite
extensions
not said there is that the january 6
rioters were all trump supporters
inspired by trump and maybe to some
degree by right-wing media
the shooting of steve scalise in 2017
really has nothing to do with this
now on the senate side mitch mcconnell
who is the senate
minority leader says that republicans
are undecided on whether to go ahead
with the commission but they're open to
hearing arguments
some republicans have already expressed
support for the commission for example
texas republican senator john cornyn
said quote
i think we need to do something to
identify the problems
i mean shame on us if we can't address
it now i asked on twitter yesterday
why would anyone be opposed to even
investigating
the january 6th riots and i received
some really interesting responses here's
a representative sample
one viewer telling me because they are
scared the truth will be told
about things they don't want anyone to
know about another
follower of mine on twitter says they i
think they mean they are connected
to those who are responsible and
therefore are complicit
and a very comprehensive answer giving
four reasons why
republicans are opposed to the
investigation a it will incriminate
their dear leader
donald trump b it will incriminate their
voters and supporters
c it will incriminate their fellow
republican congress members
and d it will incriminate themselves
let's hope that this panel is formed
and that the investigation happens now
one last thing
in the defense of some republicans
some republicans do want to do this and
i think
that's a good thing right like that's
something
and of course this should be done a
little bit later in the show
i'll tell you about man of the people
and government transparency advocate
tucker carlson
who is completely against this
investigation
really transparent right guys this is
why populism
and faux populism can be such a
pernicious thing that's a little bit
later
we learned late last night about a major
change to the scope of the current new
york attorney general's investigation
into the trump organization it is now a
criminal investigation full stop what
started as a civil
investigation into the trump
organization is
now a criminal investigation this is a
huge deal
and it at least changes the possible
path
of the probe now remember that new york
state attorney general
leticia james was already in the middle
of a civil investigation of donald
trump's company
now they are investigating the trump
organization quote in
a criminal capacity this is also
it's hard to even keep this all straight
this is not the same investigation that
sy vance jr is doing
james's spokesman says this
investigation is being conducted in
conjunction
with the criminal probe of trump and the
trump organization by the manhattan
district attorney cyrus vance
this is the attorney general of new york
now these are two criminal
investigations now
part of this is all thanks to michael
cohen donald trump's former attorney
who has said many times now that the
trump organization
misstated real estate valuations to
reduce their tax liabilities
and to get better loan and insurance
terms the full statement from
leticia james's office is short and it
is quote we have informed the trump
organization
that our investigation into the
organization is no longer purely
civil in nature we are now actively
investigating the trump organization in
a criminal
capacity along with the manhattan
district attorney
we have no additional comment at this
time
recall that leticia james is the
prosecutor
who went after the trump foundation
trump's now
dissolved charity was ordered to pay two
million dollars to settle a lawsuit by
the ag's office saying he misused
the trump foundation and its funds to
benefit his presidential campaign as
well as other unlawful
activity for more than a decade and the
trump foundation agreed to pay the fine
and they also agreed in december of 2018
to completely dissolve
and donate all remaining funds to
charity that's the same
leticia james that got that done
who is now investigating the trump
organization criminally
trump is calling both investigations
witch hunts which to me suggests wow
there's probably something here
and we will see where both
investigations go now i maintain and i
know some people get mad when i say this
i maintain trump will see no prison time
period
there will be no handcuffed perp walk
but the more that this builds
and now it has shifted from merely civil
to criminal the possibility that
someone goes to prison does go up but
almost certainly this is going to be a
massive financial burden on trump
in terms of legal bills and as i've said
before
these investigations while they're not
going to put trump in prison
they're not they could keep trump from
running in 2024 which would be amazing
it's optimistic thinking but uh
it it very well could quickly become a
massive burden for trump and if it keeps
him out of
out of candidacy in uh three and a half
years that would be a great thing now
there's one other aspect to this
there are people reacting to news
from this probe and from the sci vance
probe by saying
if it's taking this long nothing is
happening it's just going to peter out
i spoke to a couple of prosecutors i
know who said
you know from the outside you can't
really know
but often the longer the investigation
takes the stronger the case is
because they're uncovering more and more
wrongdoing and they want to be really
sure that the cases are iron-clad before
they move forward either way it's
speculative
but the point is it's not obvious it's
not certain
that the fact that this is dragging with
no charges yet is bad
um it's also important to remember at
least with the sci-vance probe
that trump was able to obstruct that
moving forward
by not providing his tax returns for his
entire presidency
only in the last couple of months did
they finally get a court decision that
said
yes trump must give saivans his taxes so
that part of the investigation
has only really now started it's been
delayed and that could be part of it as
well
one other really small thing a couple of
people wrote to me and they said
this is the real reason trump left new
york it wasn't to avoid taxes it wasn't
because
new york wasn't good to him because they
didn't vote for him in the presidential
election the real reason trump left new
york was to get away from this
investigation i just don't think so
number one trump is a narcissist and
narcissists
have this idea that no one can touch
them so i don't think trump is leaving
that doesn't make sense number two
leaving new york doesn't actually stop
the investigations
so it would be stupid in that sense and
number three
trump is really cheap and really greedy
so
leaving changing residency from new york
to florida
makes a lot of sense because avoiding
taxes is
completely on brand with donald trump's
priorities so that's
i believe that's really the reason trump
left the investigation will follow him
to florida
if that's what needs to happen and um
it will um uh trump
i don't think trump really thinks in the
terms you and i might think
of something like this so i think it's
just money and that's why trump left
new york at least as far as residency is
concerned we'll have
more on this growing multiple
investigations set
now on the davidpakmanshow instagram
make sure you're following us on
instagram at davidpakmanshow
and follow me on instagram for the
latest from my
garden nothing more riveting than that
you can find me on instagram at
david.pakman
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent better
21.
so thanks to some recently released
court documents we've learned that
multiple of the accused rioters from the
january 6th insurrection attempt
tried to use the legal defense
donald trump made me do it now they
tried but at least
so far it's been unsuccessful because
the court
said no way and in fact one of the
people who tried this
is that guy known as the q anon shaman
jacob chansley who was photographed in
the house chamber wearing like a viking
hat of some kind
and his lawyer was actually um
uh making the case that
what um jacob chansley did
would not have happened were it not for
the words
and the actions of president donald
trump his lawyer said
if it weren't for trump my client your
honor
would never even have been in washington
dc in support of the president and
were it not for the specific words of
the then president on january 6th
saying we're going to march down
pennsylvania avenue or whatever
the defendant would not have walked down
pennsylvania avenue and would never have
gone near never mind inside the u.s
capitol building
saying my client did it because donald
trump told him to
this was part of his lawyer trying to
get him out on bail instead of having
him
stay in pre-trial detention and his
lawyer argued he's not dangerous
he wasn't even sincerely there due to
his own beliefs it was just because of
trump
trump made him do it and the judge in
the case royce lamberth
said quote even taking defendant's claim
at face value
it does not persuade the court that the
defendant would not pose a danger to
others if released
if the defendant truly believes that the
only reason he participated
in an assault on the u.s capitol was to
comply with president trump's orders
this shows the defendant's inability or
refusal to exercise his independent
judgment
and conform his behavior to the law
in other words the judge is saying if
trump really convinced him to do it
it's still on him and that doesn't tell
me if i release him he won't be a threat
because someone else could convince him
to do something such just as dangerous
or stupid
whether he believes trump wants him to
do it
has nothing to do with whether his
actions conform with the law and you
might remember
the other version of this that we talked
about i think it was a couple of weeks
ago
a defendant's lawyer in another one of
these rioters lawyers
claimed that the accused was suffering
from
quote foxitis and quote
foxmania and that it is fox news
rather than donald trump that are to
blame now big picture
this is not a valid legal excuse
answering someone else's call to break
the law
doesn't make it irrelevant that you
still broke the law
but there are cases when if someone was
really manipulated or forced into
breaking the law i mean
in a way i'm not comparing trump to
charles manson but
when you look at the charles manson case
charles manson
if i recall correctly i mean this is
just occurring to me now
if i recall correctly charles manson
himself did not actually kill anyone but
he directed others to do it and yet he
was found legally guilty
because he brainwashed manipulated
others etc there are circumstances where
if you were really manipulated or forced
into breaking the law and forced into
breaking the law is
an even different thing courts can
consider that and it can impact
guilt versus innocence and it can impact
sentencing but under
federal statutes in this particular
situation the law wouldn't see the trump
defense as a valid defense it wouldn't
see fox itis and fox mania
as valid defenses just because a nutty
childish clown
tells you to do something even if that
someone is the president
does not make it a valid legal defense
particularly when you are dealing with
these
specific federal statutes but this is
sort of a version of stochastic
terrorism as i've said before
it's really hard to hold people
accountable for that but if you have a
large enough audience
if remember glenn beck when he used to
have i think it was a
fox news or cnn show glenn beck ranting
about the tides foundation which he
became obsessed with every day
statistically someone in his audience is
going to hear that and say i'm going to
go and do something about the tides
foundation in case in point there was a
guy arrested
by california highway patrol driving to
the tides foundation to do
who the hell knows what with a large
enough audience when you start
saying someone should do x and if only
someone did y
the likelihood that at least one person
in this case hundreds or thousands of
people will try to do it goes up and up
and up it's almost it's kind of like a
silly version
of the nuremberg defense the difference
being
none of these people are in the chain of
command the trump rioters were not
in the chain of command where you could
even say i was following orders in a
sense
there were no risks or punishments if
you just stayed the hell home if the q
anon shaman said you know what
instead of going to dc i'll stay at home
no one was going to punish him for that
there was not going to be any
risk to doing that he would have been
fine and so that also
um furthers the reason why it's not a
particularly good
defense now even if it doesn't make a
difference for these specific people
the funny or maybe the ir ironic thing
in people pointing to trump as the
reason why they did this
could be something that comes up in a
justice department investigation or a
house congressional investigation into
trump's role
but i don't expect that will go very far
at least at holding donald trump
accountable
the other possibility is that while
claiming
trump made me do it might make no
difference
in their criminal trials civil trials
are a whole different
thing and one lawyer wrote to me and
said the trump made me do it defense
could be something that plays a role in
a civil trial
if there were to be one last thought it
is not beyond me
the irony of people who claim to
represent a political ideology that
preaches and values and prioritizes
personal responsibility
who then get charged with crimes that
they did and immediately claim as their
defenses
fox news convinced me or trump made me
do it
it's pitiful it's pitiful and pathetic
and it is again a reminder
that their stated values and principles
are merely stated
they are not really sincerely held
values and principles they abandoned
them
abandoned them instantly when it's no
longer convenient
one of the notable people who does not
want an investigation
into just what on earth happened in
washington dc on january 6th
as trump supporters broke into the
capitol
is fox news propagandist tucker carlson
it's all as much of a riot as you can
imagine
we already discussed earlier in the show
that
many in the republican party including
republican leaders like
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
they don't want
the january 6th investigation to happen
um
and here tucker carlson praises kevin
mccarthy
for opposing the investigation recall
that tucker carlson is very much a man
of the people
he's a populist he's for transparencies
for accountability
he's for all of that stuff but he
doesn't even want
an investigation to take place and here
he is uh
attaboying kevin mccarthy this is not a
partisan show
we usually go after democrats sometimes
we go after republicans recently when
after a couple of times the
head republican in the house of
representatives kevin mccarthy of
california
for his living arrangements but we want
to be honest above all
and when politicians do something right
we want to say so
kevin mccarthy the minority leader in
the house today did something right he
said he will not support
a commission a 911 style commission to
investigate the
insurrection of january 6. tucker is
defiantly proud
of kevin mccarthy for opposing a
commission
to investigate the january 6th
insurrection it's also hilarious to hear
tucker say
he doesn't do a partisan show i mean
that's we could do 15 minutes on that
but we won't
tucker is actually so opposed to an
investigation
that he wants to take names of all
republicans who vote in favor of
it because some do plan to the exact
number
is yet unclear take a listen the top
republican on the house homeland
security committee
is apparently pushing for this 911 style
commission
one anonymous house republican told the
hill that anywhere from between 30 and
50
republicans might join catco in voting
for this farce
what are they voting for they're voting
to give nancy pelosi chuck schumer and
joe biden more power
power they do not deserve power they did
not win in november
republican voters deserve to know the
names of every congressional republican
who votes for this farce for the myth
making that is being used right now to
strip you of your constitutional rights
they should know which of the
representatives is playing along with
this poisonous hoax
so clearly tucker painting this as some
kind of partisan witch hunt
when the truth is that some republicans
are saying
they support the commission because it's
being done in a bipartisan way
not only is there bipartisan support for
the commission
not only are there bipartisan sponsors
for the commission the plan right now
would be that the commission would have
ten members democrats get to a point
five republicans get to a point five
democrats appoint the chair
and republicans appoint the vice chair
remember democrats control the house
so the closest you can get to it being
perfectly bipartisan is five and five
democrats because they control the house
pick the chair republicans get the vice
chair and the commission
would only be able to issue subpoenas if
they're signed off on by both
the democratic chair of the commission
and the republican vice chair so
you know you couldn't even have a
situation where democrats alone
start issuing all sorts of subpoenas the
republican vice chair
would have to be on board with every
single subpoena
and yet tucker doesn't like it flames
frames it as some kind of farce because
god forbid
we should ever find out what really
happened on that day and the causes and
the explanations for why things went
down the way they did but as we said
earlier
if you were complicit you wouldn't want
to support it
and defendants accused in the january 6
trump riots have actually tried
two of them at least blaming fox news
and blaming president donald trump
neither has worked so far but blaming
fox news
tucker carlson is a part of fox news and
it seems pretty clear
that he would be against such an
investigation because it can't possibly
be good for him
i'm not saying the probe would bring
down tucker i'm not saying it would get
him to lose his show or get him charged
with a crime none of that would happen
but if you're tucker it wouldn't be good
for more attention especially in
congressional hearings
to be on the alleged role of fox news in
fomenting the riots that's very clear so
it does make sense
in that way that tucker would be opposed
to it now on the other hand
the white house does back a january 6th
commission
and really one should have been formed
on january 7th maybe may of 2021 is the
best we can get at the end of the day
if they can't get republican leadership
to support it i think they probably will
but if they can't
just go ahead without republican
leadership they can find republicans who
will be on the commission because
there's enough republicans already at
least 20
who want to do the investigation some of
those republicans
will participate in good faith to try to
get some answers
and the republicans that remain on the
sidelines screaming this is a partisan
witch hunt
i don't think they'll make much of a
difference democrats should continue
to focus on the 70 of the country that
sees biden doing well on kovid and they
say yeah biden's doing well on covet
they see biden doing well on vaccination
and they say yeah the vaccination
rollout is going well
just proceed because i think you'll have
an equivalent 70
of the country that understands the
importance of doing this probe
and will support doing it if you
disagree and if you think there's
political risk to going forward without
republicans
in the leadership supporting it they've
got republicans that will be on the
commission
let me know i don't see it as a risk i
think democrats should move forward one
way or the other let me know your
thoughts
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as
well read about them all right these are
my favorite clips today this is so funny
uh today on the bonus show
when i'm joined by producer pat we will
talk
about how suddenly rudy giuliani's son
andrew giuliani is running for governor
of new york
and he appeared on fox news last night
and gave a completely bizarre and
farcical interview
but eric trump didn't want andrew
giuliani to outdo him apparently
so i can't actually tell who gave the
dumbest appearance last night on fox
news let's take a quick listen we're
going to start with eric trump
donald trump's son not the smartest one
i don't think
and eric trump claims that random people
are coming up to him on the street
crying
in tears over how much they want donald
trump back as president take a look at
this
um you know more people i mean i i can
tell you more people have come up to me
on the street in the last week and given
me hugs saying
we miss him so much i mean literally
sometimes sean with tears in their eyes
we miss the man so much
no matter what what you say about him he
loves this country and he's willing to
fight for this
does anybody believe this like i do
believe that
tears have been shed related to trump as
president
but i don't think that their their tears
of joy
uh then eric trump claims that
this white house doesn't travel and that
that's really bad
but listen to the complete inconsistency
of what he even tries to assert here
there's no fight coming out of the white
house there's no one there they don't
travel they don't go down to the border
they don't go overseas they don't
i mean there's no charisma there's no
there's no anything did you guys catch
that
he says this white house is bad because
it doesn't trap
it doesn't travel and this white house
is bad because there's no one at the
white house
well hold on a second if they're not at
the white house and they're not
traveling like where are they where is
joe biden
is it that's is there is the president
just missing he's he can't be found
anywhere he's not doing any trial
is he at camp david the entire time just
vapid
pointless talking points not even really
a criticism so that's eric trump
that's already really bad but then
in comes andrew giuliani he is running
for governor
of new york state this is rudy
giuliani's son
he's 35 years old he went on tv last
night
and declared anything that will bring
money to new york
he will do period full stop end of story
take a listen well look let's start off
with sports gambling i don't much how
much time we have
anything that's going to bring revenue
into new york i am pro that
a lot of people that i know go to new
jersey in order to actually go
and gamble you really feel
like the republican party has no farm
team right now
it's q anon type people like marjorie
taylor green
lauren beaubert and others they may be
the future of the republican party but
it's a really scary future if that's the
future
you then have your trump brown nosers
who aren't they're not even really young
but they might potentially aspire to
higher office people like kevin mccarthy
or tom cotton josh hawley these types of
people
and then there's the children of
well-known republicans
andrew giuliani the son of rudy giuliani
donald trump jr
eric trump ivanka trump the children of
donald trump
it's not looking great for the country
and many of them may win like i'm not
saying this looks bad for the republican
party
in the sense that they won't ever win
again trump won
so there's a very real risk that these
clowns could win
it's just not looking good for the
country the fact that uh
these are people who are not immediately
and obviously disqualified
from any role in public office or in
government now
um andrew giuliani seems to have sort of
a savior complex
here he was on hannity last night saying
he will save
the state of new york you just wait you
wait until 2023
and then we're going to have a nice big
party up in albany and we're going to
see you're going to be at empire state
so i don't know which appearance was
more hair brained
eric trump's or andrew giuliani's now
here's a couple of bonus
andrew giuliani clips by the way here he
is yesterday
getting ready to make his announcement
and he seemed confused about whether the
statue he was looking at
was the statue of liberty or some other
statue i mean it's
i i don't know take a look at this okay
let me know whenever you're ready
which one is that is that miss manhattan
or is that lady that's lady liberty over
there everybody ready
yeah so that's that's something and then
lastly
really funny andrew giuliani said at his
announcement
that he will use his dad rudy giuliani
as an asset i mean you you can't write
this stuff rudy giuliani seems to have
been used as an asset
by so many people in countries at this
point and andrew giuliani apparently
with no sense of satire or parody
whatsoever and certainly no comic timing
that's for sure
saying he will use rudy as an asset take
a look when you've got the greatest
prosecutor in the history of the
southern district and you've got the
greatest mayor not this
not just in the history of new york but
in the history of america
you're foolish if you don't use him as
an asset so we are
in for a real party here
with andrew giuliani running for
governor these families you know the
trumps the giuliani's
they're in a sense the gifts that keep
on giving
but it is a major indictment of american
society and culture
that people like this can actually
attain power
and then that their kids are seen as at
least possibly legitimate
inheritors it heirs inheritors heirs to
that power
is inheritors a word i don't know
certainly ayers is
uh heirs to that power it is an
indictment of the united states of
america
and the world sees it they laugh we've
said it before um
truly truly horrible stuff uh this is
super interesting and not altogether
uh surprising the daily beast has a
fascinating piece uh somewhat lengthy
not not huge but uh
take a few minutes to read about how
rudy giuliani
seems to have the walls closing in
around him in terms of these
investigations that are going on
and donald trump seems to have abandoned
him completely which is
absolutely on brand for donald trump uh
this is a piece in the daily beast which
we will link to
written by adam ronsley and azawin
subseng which writes in the weeks since
the feds raided rudy giuliani's
apartment
and office in late april close to close
allies have tried to ferry a slew of
emergency requests to former president
donald trump and his advisors
but according to three people familiar
with the matter trump
and his legal advisers and confidants
have been hesitant
about swooping in to help the embattled
giuliani
who for years worked as trump's personal
attorney political advisor
and attack dog understand what's going
on
rudy's in trouble the walls are closing
in around rudy
they raided his home they raided his
office it's
looking really bad for rudy and rudy
is sending these massive dumps for lack
of a better term of requests
to trump and his advisors for help for
interference for whatever
some kind of intervention and trump is
just ignoring it
the daily beast piece goes on to say
team trump's reluctance to intervene
comes at a time when federal
investigators have ramped up their probe
into whether giuliani's ukraine-related
work during the trump era
amounted to an unregistered and illegal
lobbying operation on behalf of foreign
figures
so far no charges have been brought
trump's silence has led to simmering
frustrations
among members of giuliani's inner orbit
who privately allege that the
ex-president's team is working to
convince him to hang giuliani out to dry
in his hour of need that's another level
and that would be
absolutely compelling we've been keeping
an eye but not
talking too much about donald trump's
blogs
on his website and so far he has not
come to the defense of rudy giuliani but
he's also not hung rudy giuliani out to
dry
i think that if this escalates
and it gets to the point where it's
clear rudy is going to be charged
i do think trump will publicly abandon
rudy and say he was he was off script
he was doing his own thing he was not
representing me
um one person close to giuliani said
last week
quote it's a question now of whether or
not trump wants to leave
rudy to fend for himself or if they're
going to take a stand against this
right now we don't know among the pleas
like what is rudy asking for among the
pleas
have been for trump to issue a strong
verbal or written statement
saying giuliani's work during the trump
ukraine saga was done on behalf
of trump there's no way in hell trump
says that because trump needs to leave
the possibility if rudy gets charged
of saying the ukraine stuff had nothing
to do with me i had a perfect phone call
and that's it whatever rudy was doing i
don't know about
the other asks have been that trump sign
onto a legal motion
to have federal investigators throw out
any seized communications
that rudy and his lawyers are arguing
are covered by attorney-client privilege
and further there have been requests
that trump and his team
financially help rudy in his legal
defense
apparently rudy's legal expenses are
going
absolutely crazy now that's what the
rudy people want trump to do
on the other hand and this is a really
great piece that looks at both sides of
this in the daily beast
two people close to trump they write say
they have urged
trump to lay low and refrain from making
too many statements one way or the other
these people have told trump it's
unclear what the feds have
and anything trump says could backfire
on him and on giuliani that is exactly
why
trump would never come out and say rudy
was working on behalf of me
because they don't know what they have
on rudy yet and if it's really bad if
they have rudy dead to rights trump now
saying
everything rudy did he did it for me it
implicates donald trump
so this shouldn't surprise anybody
who understands how donald trump
operates look at trump with his voters
trump defends them they're beautiful
people uh
there's my african-american and the
hispanics love me and the suburban women
these are all great people
as long as they're useful to him but as
soon as they're not
like for example on january 6th trump
turned on the tv
and he saw the rioters who were all
trumpists
and he said these people look kind of
low class they're making me look bad
and then he abandons them trump
grifting what was it 70 million from his
supporters
for legal battles after the november
election
that we're never going to go anywhere
trump's scamming his supporters saying i
will fight this and i will
audit that and do a recount here and
more than half the money went just to
pay off
trump's uh campaign debt why
because at that point the election was
over
the only way that these people were
useful to trump was trying to grift some
money
out of them and it's the same way with
trump's lawyers and cronies
he abandoned michael cohen and
when trump has political allies he loves
them while they're allies as soon as
they some
say something even mildly critical uh
trump abandons them
so the one thing about this uh
that is that is predictable and on brand
is trump's not going to come to anyone's
defense unless it's useful to him
and right now coming out and saying rudy
did great work and it was all for me
that possibly implicates donald trump
they don't know how bad uh rudy is in
trouble at this point in time
um one other interesting aspect from
this daily beast article which says
quote
in recent weeks trump himself has argued
behind closed doors
that he wouldn't want to say giuliani
was doing all of the ukraine work
which included a transatlantic dirt
digging expedition on the biden family
on trump's behalf trump's reasoning
is based on the ex-president's
insistence that he didn't always know
what giuliani was doing during the
ukraine effort
or concocting with his ukrainian pals
several of whom trump has privately
dinged as idiots
so apparently this is something trump is
saying
privately it's actually possible that
that is to some degree true but that
doesn't tell us trump didn't have a
sense of what was going on
very often someone in a role as powerful
as president of the united states
would be deliberately kept out of the
loop as to the specifics of what his
henchmen are doing
and when you're in that position you
know you're being kept out of the loop
like in other words
you may you know it's a known unknown
you know you're not being told exactly
what rudy's up to you know the gist of
it
but you're not being told the specifics
in order to keep you potentially out of
trouble
um if something exactly like this would
happen so the last thing anyone would do
in this situation is to say
i knew everything he was doing and he
was doing it all for me now one last
thing here
okay that this goes back to trump's
narcissism
um some people are saying
uh obviously trump
isn't going to help someone who has
mountains of dirt
on him because trump's worried it will
come back on him
but isn't there a risk that rudy if
trump doesn't help him will release all
the dirt he has on trump
trump doesn't think this way trump is a
narcissist
trump cannot conceive of anybody turning
on him in that way
if they did so what he's donald trump
it's not like anything bad can happen
anything donald trump does in his mind
is legal and good because it's something
he did
and that would never happen so i know
you and i might say you know it's a
double-edged sword because on one hand
on the one hand trump doesn't want to
defend giuliani because that could come
back to bite him on the other hand if
trump doesn't
rudy could release whatever dirt he has
on trump trump the narcissist doesn't
think the dirt rudy has could really
damage him in a serious way that's what
you have to remember
about how the narcissist thinks so we'll
see what happens let me know if you
think there are charges forthcoming for
rudy i think uh
i i just don't know and it's not because
i don't think rudy did some horrible
things it's similar to gates
we have a two-tier justice system in
this country we know that people in
positions of power
often are not subject to the same uh
circumstances
that other people are uh so i just i
genuinely don't know what to expect in
terms of charges against rudy but
let me know your thoughts we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
david p
here is a delightful caller thrilled
that she got vaccinated she's telling
random strangers listen to the joy in
her voice
i love you hi david this is laurel from
washington
yes and i was just watching the youtube
video about the guy who calls up and is
threatening you because
you gave faxing advice no you didn't
anyhow i just called you to tell you
because i want to tell everybody
total strangers on the street have been
telling i've got both my doses
i am so happy so just my husband so does
my son
we're totally vaccinated house
and we are happy i am with you laurel i
am truly with you i wish more people
would do the exact same thing because
we know the path out of the pandemic we
see the data we see what's happening in
highly vaccinated countries we see
what's happening in the u.s
particularly in the most highly
vaccinated states there's no mystery
here folks
there's really no mystery all right so
let's uh let's do it
on today's bonus show we will talk about
the political aspect of rudy giuliani's
son running for governor of new york
particularly when rudy himself
is potentially in a very bad
investigative situation with the walls
closing in around him what is that going
to look like
number two bank of america will raise
its minimum wage to
25 per hour
by 2025. wow
wow or is it we will talk about it and
also
texas moving very quickly no masks are
required
at just about every texas state facility
anymore
is this logical based on the numbers is
this risky
if yes for who all of those questions
and hopefully some answers on today's
bonus show
get instant access to the bonus show two
ways become a member at joinpacman.com
or become a patron at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow both ways you get
instant access to the bonus show it is a
good one today
and i hope to see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person
by letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman